I so by now you know me you know what
I'm like II know that no matter what's
happening in the world
I'll take time out of my day to talk
about Mortal Kombat because I me the
Mortal Kombat so let's talk about the PS
Vita version Mortal Kombat for the PS
Vita
so Mortal Kombat's been ported from the
PlayStation 3 or Xbox 360 depending on
what system you have to the PS Vita
which is a portable system which just
screams yet it's gonna be missing
content which is really funny thing
because when I was playing the PS Vita
version I was like I feel like I've
played this game before I've already
reviewed Mortal Kombat for the ps3 you
want to check out my review you still
can it's still relevant so I felt like
this reviewed be kind of repetitive and
that's actually pretty much the best
compliment I can give the PS Vita
version of Mortal Kombat I mean if the
portable version feels that much like
the console version that's pretty much
what we're going for right Mortal Kombat
for the Vita has everything that you
loved about the ps3 version you know it
has all the LEDs all the characters all
the combos all the special moves the one
thing it doesn't have is the God of War
level which I kind of hated that was
like come on that's a cool level you
know it's a stage fatality you could
pick one of three ways they can die I
wasn't in it I don't know but I was sad
but in the world of give and take when
that's like pretty much the major give
I'll take that but the gameplay is just
as fast as it was on the ps3 you know
all the combos are there is just fast
fast fast I was blown away as to how
exact the combat is from the ps3 version
to the PS Vita version good job in other
own Studios I'm porting this yet they
nerf the graphics yeah they did you're
gonna have to I mean Mortal Kombat's a
big game now you're getting into the PS
Vita but you really only notice it when
they're doing their intro you know like
Liu Kang comes up as like show me what
you can do and it shows like pretty much
from here to here a close-up of the
character you know before they fight
that's when you're like woo aim your if
those graphics but when it zooms out the
screen stationary it's like round 1
fight and throughout the fight you don't
really notice the graphics have taken a
hit at all I mean if you're a real
shading nozzle you're gonna nose like
the Bloods less shiny and the guts and
the body parts don't glimmer but other
than that the gameplay pulls you right
in and you really don't care that the
graphics have taken a bit of a hit if
you notice them at all while you're
fighting in the world of graphics or
gameplay
I'll take gameplay any day of the week
and it has all the downloadable
characters scarlet rain Kenji Freddy
Krueger and Kratos he was in the ps3
version he's in the Vita version
although his levels not now the PS Vita
version does have some unique content
also it has a hundred and fifty new
challenges for the challenge tower it's
actually a new challenge Howard's bonus
challenge tower
and 50 new challenges Alvida specific
you know you have to like tilt the vita
you got to shake it to get the screen
right you know you gotta like tap
rockets that are coming after you some
are fun some are hard some make you want
to throw your video out the window it's
pretty much classic Mortal Kombat fun
and so frustrating and as the PS Vita
version has all the DLC content for the
ps3 this challenge tower is how you
unlock all the classic costumes you know
kind of gives you something to work for
you're like why would I do 150
challenges why would I frustrate the
[ __ ] out of myself a lot of costumes
okay we'll do that another feature they
have is the PS Vita is a touchscreen so
you can just touch your x-ray meter and
he'll do the x-ray move all you have to
do is tap your thumb down you know it's
not too much extra effort but it is
easier just to push ellinor at the same
time however my favorite feature I'm not
really a gimmicky person but I like this
feature you can swipe the touchscreen to
do the fatalities all you need to do is
the motion example if you know you're
doing Johnny Cage as fatality it's for
for back down X right up next to him you
push forward for back down X and somehow
you screw it up because it's a fatality
and you're going to X is an attack so if
you screw it up he'll smack them in the
head you can't do the fatality it's all
over but on the PS Vita version just
swipe forward forward back down that's
all you have to do he'll do the fatality
if you screw it up well you just push
forward for back down he's not going to
smack him you can just do it again
99% of the time when I'm doing a
fatality I'll just swipe the touchscreen
it's really responsive I like however if
you want to do the normal button
combinations for the fatalities you can
do that too and this what I like about
the touchscreen gimmicks in this game
you want to use the touchscreen to do
your x-ray move you can do that or you
can do L&R if you want to use the
touchscreen gimmicks to do the
fatalities you can do that or you can do
the button combinations SL gimmicks
should be there should be an option not
like a thing you have to do but the
crappy thing is with the Tag battles you
know the ps3 version you do one of the
tag moves you use one of the L&R buttons
and a tags your guy and he does a
special move our tags them in for battle
in this one you have to swipe the right
analog button to the right it's just in
the heat of battle it's really awkward
I'm not even being sarcastic if there is
a negative to this game it's that got
all the fatalities the special moves the
alibies the characters the graphics have
taken a bit of a nerf but the gameplay
sucks you right in and you just don't
care plus you can't tell smaller screens
mean you can hide blemishes better
should you get mortal combat for the PS
video if you have a vida y a horrible
Mortal Kombat it's everything I have
wanted especially since the last
portable MK game I have was Mortal
Kombat for the Game Gear oh yeah I
rocked that Game Gear I am amazed that
they packed this much content into one
cartridge good job guys I don't know
about you but there been times I'll just
be somewhere you know maybe you're at a
shitty job or something you're like oh
man
me I had Mortal Kombat in the palm of my
hand Oh BAM now you do you haven't
thought I have thought of that this is
the Mortal Kombat that one fighting game
of the Year for 2011 on many websites in
the palm of your hand it's just as
simple as that
so Mortal Kombat what's your favorite
character in Mortal Kombat whichever it
is
whatever he is whoever she is I meant
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see
[Music]